[Music]
Carrie Underwood gets handed in her
first TV interview since her scary fall
back in November well just kind of a
freak accident I just fell I just
tripped taking my dogs out to do their
business Carrie opened up on Thursdays
today's show about her road to recovery
after being left with a broken wrist and
more than 40 stitches on her face in the
beginning I mean I feel like you know I
didn't know how things were gonna end up
and in what way what do you mean just
you just I mean there was it just wasn't
pretty I feel like you look the same
thank you I have a dedicated team of
professionals who can speckle and paint
and paste
thank you I I'm feeling everyday I feel
a little more a little more back to
normal
[Music]
since the accident the cry pretty singer
has performed her new single at the ACM
Awards and she says the response to her
music has been touching I feel like
people are telling me places that they
cry I've heard cause it
I heard shower I've heard bathroom
what's yours I feel like my car kind of
is good yeah I feel like you just feel
like which I know people can still see
you and they probably have seen me at
like a stoplight or something and you're
like what's this crazy lady she's moving
over there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]